les taiwanais l'insee choix nastorg
voient leur avenir ensemble différemment
maintenant que le parlement de leur pays
y est de légaliser le mariage gay une
première en asie
c'est une loi spéciale mais au moins
nous aurons la même protection que
mariage hétérosexuel sociaux définis
dans le code civil art livin son
compagnon un photographe qui se
spécialise dans les mariages est aussi
enthousiaste devant cette première il
n'y a rien de mal à être les premiers
dans le futur prostate est une source de
fierté pense-t-il
les députés taîwanais ont voté à forte
majorité une loi permettant aux couples
homosexuels de former des unions
permanent exclusive et qui les autorise
à s'inscrire au registre des mariages en
la cour constitutionnelle de lille avait
jugé le fait de priver les personnes de
même sexe du droit de se marier
contraire à la constitution
elle avait donné deux ans gouvernement
pour modifier la loi ce qui a été fait
l'opposition conservatrice s'était
mobilisée mais n'a pu empêcher le
parlement de voter le texte le plus
progressiste soutenue par la communauté
lgbt milliers de partisans de cette
réforme s'était rassemblée près du
parlement et la pluie existants des
drapeaux arc en ciel lorsque la nouvelle
est tombée
pour ce militant lgbt et taïwan en
maintenant la liberté de choisir pour
qu'ils votent et avec qui il veut se
marier chine continentale ne peut pas en
dire autant des voix ne prévoit pas une
des qualités total pour autant c'est
l'adoption de l'enfant biologique du
père tonnerre est autorisé et les
mariages avec les étrangers ne sont pas
reconnus ici une chaîne marsolais radio
canada montréal